[Music] Hi
Nishimura-san,
Yukiko-san, what are you shopping for? Is that bag at a bookstore
? Yes, there's a book I want to read, and you seem like
someone who likes books, but yeah, that's right. No,
my younger brother won't be coming to my house after this.  It's
not a lesson, but
yeah, yeah, yeah, that
[music]
Yeah, it's really cute. I ca
n't get clothes like this. It's my hand-me-down anyway, so if Mr.
Nishimura doesn't wear it, I'll just
give it to my younger brother. It
really suits Takada-kun.  It's
cute.
Smile, smile, and be
But if I
wear cute clothes, everyone in my class
will laugh at me. Why,
even though I look great in them, my nickname is Shinigami, and that's a
cool nickname. Besides, I don't wear clothes like that.  It has
nothing to do with that. Don't be afraid to wear what you want.
But if you're being mean to me, you
can ask my younger brother to help you out.
But then,
you're the one who's having the most fun, Takada-
kun.  Also, the Taiyo family often
talks about Nishimura-san.
And when they talk about Nishimura-san, it's
amazing. He looks happy, so this is serious. Thank you very much.
But he's really cute. I
want to show him to Taiyo soon. He's
really
cute.
[Music]